okay time to judge people's house tours
again where i'm overly critical for no
reason but entertainment starting off
with pokemane pokemon pokemon i realize
this is not a house tour it's a it's a
room tour just the room but we also get
hallway bonus hallway
uh tour english i like the flooring it's
a nice wood looks comfortable on your
feet to walk barefoot on okay there's
don't trip the stairs
[Music]
oh oh my god that's so funny oh ken
taught me i can do this yeah
yeah okay
my brain operates so fast i saw the door
and i'm like oh god they have glass
doors
in this whole
setup that's gonna be terrible audio
leakage and then lo and behold they put
the sound cushions on them i don't think
they actually what is it called they
just don't make echo they don't dampen
the noise maybe they do i don't know i
don't care here we are pokeman
[Music]
okay
a bunch of stuff
awesome
[Music]
all right
okay
uh-huh
i don't know what to say this is so
girly how do i judge this
oh yeah the stuff on the door
oh yeah what about the stuff in the door
no that is is that is that soundproofing
i thought that just doesn't make it echo
sometimes things can get a little bit
loud can someone buy me
oh my god they even made a whole segment
about it jesus bro pokey pokey
pokey smokey bulky [ __ ] monkey bucky
that's your display setup that looks so
uncomfortable am i how good is their
vision how are they so far away maybe
that's better for yourself it's
obviously my pc setup and probably what
i see that's a tiniest little baby
display
bucky bucky
but we have the same microphone nice
come on
get big big display large
so huge come on
come on come on dude come on get out of
here how many hours a day do you stream
come on you staring at that
interested in baby
probably the only part of my room that
i've really showcased i try not to
showcase too much just for security
purposes until i like the rilakkuma
that's too much and then that's when i
do my room tour so i am moving in three
days really really excited a little bit
nervous yeah so at my pc setup we have
come on oh and pokey actually keeps her
headlights not directing to her face
because that's how you're supposed to
let your
setup
ah you know what it's better
no one teach you how to like in school
now you broke them pokey are you happy
god damn it how's my face now oh so good
thanks pokeyman thanks a lot now my wall
is super bright what if i amp it up this
is garbage i've been lighted now film
school eat your heart out what the [ __ ]
is this
give me that i need to blast out all my
blemishes
come on just like makeup and lipsticks
and stuff like that for if i ever want
to touch up while streaming and warmers
just random things that i i can't get
over the displays oh god the cable
management oh god pokey smokey pokey
bra what is that what am i looking at i
see it around my desk area it's all i
see now
no i'm sorry you lost setup privileged
oh god oh god
yeah pokey
why
the last setup i put it here because
my feet can't really properly reach
the ground without it
and you gotta have 90 degrees at your
step correct ergonomically correct and
her displays are also ergonomically
correct so well done bonus points for
that pokey however boogie boogie
just get one of these
come on come on
it's so soft
this that looks good come on and fix
your cable all right while we're at it
like a tube get one of these tubes there
we go all right 12 pounds yeah get one
of these 12 pounds
12 pounds how much is your whole setup
this is your cable management
sorry board moving on
okay not youtuber i think he has a
youtube channel so count as youtuber
justin bieber's tour bus i'm always
fascinated by
like luxury on the road because any sort
of normal things that you have in the
house is obviously a luxury or in a car
so it's like you have a washing machine
in your bus
what's wrong with this voice what the
[ __ ] have you ever driven the bus
yeah i don't think that'd be a good idea
what the hell happened what's this thank
you i'm justin bieber come check out my
tour
bus damn
is that old for him
[Music]
um absolutely demolish the ottawa
senators
it's 5'4
it's looking good
um so much to take in what the [ __ ] i
don't know
what what is it with like there's always
a certain look for like camper vans and
and buses it's like can't can't you just
make them feel like a home this looks so
what am i looking at i don't know i hate
it here's where i set up it's obviously
luxury is amazing i'm not going to say
that it isn't but it looks i sit here i
just say
when we're on the road i sit here as
comfortable as hell get emails done and
stuff
[Music]
what if you get cars sick in a bus like
that
[Music]
there is a
it's not real but it's a fireplace here
which is kind of my brain just like how
do you fit a gaming setup on that desk
you think the wi-fi is good on the road
[ __ ] you probably couldn't oh god
dude touring life seems if you're alone
in a tour bus that just sounds
depressing but with friends i'm sure
it's amazing that's a cool aesthetic
that's dope i like that
we got
some art here by um my friend joe
termini and it's uh
some of my favorite art it's called
you check it out here
[Music]
a little cringy name but
you know
favorite bus memory wow okay well one
time it was me alfredo
and another friend and we made this
music video it was really low quality we
made it on like a flip cam or something
and it was like a 10 hour bus ride and
we made this video to a drake song
called uh find your loving i better find
you love it i don't know if that's what
the song is called but anyways we were
on the bus and we had strobe like just
not real strobe lights oh my god he's so
bad at telling a story jesus christ
first of all is alfredo i don't know who
the [ __ ] alfredo is can you hear where
people do that yeah i mean uh
shabeko we had a crazy time like
implying i know who chebeko is
i don't know my set my friend just say
my friend
goddamn shebeco but we had like a
flash and you know what you lost me i
don't care this is where i will sleep on
the road when i
travel okay that's comfy as hell it
looks better than my bed what the [ __ ]
not fair
[Music]
i like that snug babe i i'm snug bed
line snug bed again i want walls all
around me that's how you sleep
i hate the pillow though i'm no pillow
on the bed gang
i don't understand it no pills on my
baby
unless i sleep on them which she
technically is damn it on the road uh
this is where i where i sleep so i no
way no way he sleeps there wait sorry
what did i read that right he's got a
[ __ ]
sauna on a bus
okay now we reverse what i said before
sauna is like a luxury in a normal home
you got this on a bus
what
we got
a shower
it has
a steam feature in it which it's got
steam feature i don't have steam feature
you got it on your bus i love steamy
shower
it's pretty cool
and then here's pretty cool there's an
infrared sauna which is my favorite
what's so cool about this is when i'm on
tour yeah i gotta make sure that i keep
my body on optimal
level because there's so much uh that
goes into
touring and it's really hard on your
body um you're doing like an hour and an
hour and a half show a night which is
similar to a professional athlete no i
understand it goes hard what does
optimal body mean like how does sauna
help tell me my what stuff for my face
and my brushing of my teeth my good
good stuff
there's a compartment downstairs down
no joke he has more storage for his
bathroom than i do stuff what the [ __ ] i
tend to share clothes
over here there's some more clothes some
more clothes in here more closet space
as well
are you kidding me i mean i don't need
it but still he traveled from my home in
canada all the way to my place in l.a
that's cool
that's cool that you can do that you can
pull this out and this becomes almost
like a little
bed
like this you have to remove the pillows
right what oh no it just flicks out
oh that's comfy
yeah we got the cost big i saw it
okay that was it cool
i have a bus like this too except it's
attached to a concrete foundation it
doesn't move and i call it mass nice
i'm supposed to rate it i forgot about
that i keep forgetting i i rate it's not
really a house i don't really know how
to judge [ __ ] and bieber isn't really a
bus either so i'm gonna leave them out
for now and we'll get to an actual house
tour now sorry jeffree star everybody
welcome back to my dream house tour i
think he's trying to sell it now hi how
are ya
oh my god you guys uh
no i don't care is that shane oh that's
weird when was this is that
pre-cancelled oh this is weird i i'm in
another era okay here we go here sounds
dude what the [ __ ] this entrance the
floor this feels like
very uh versace
[Applause]
the double staircase god i have the
double staircase
obviously
are you lost
oh in the ceiling jesus christ this is
too much come on
[Applause]
is that what room is that that's like an
um
security offices looks like
the most esteemed pristine office ever
what the [ __ ]
what there's no cameras oh there are
okay cool cameras
i'm not gonna do a bargain house and i
think a lot of people may be shocked by
that
but i just wanna i don't know i'm just
no this is exactly what i thought what
i'm overwhelmed
god
oh man
doesn't it
okay i'm not a i'm not a jeffree stand
but like come on the feeling of this
room it's awful the lighting is terrible
it doesn't feel like homey right like
look around it am i the only one it's
got a horrible feeling to it and i can't
explain why everything feels cold and
scattered
i'm overwhelmed what is that like secret
entrance
that you can get through three different
ways are you going to make it a like
everyone comes in and they're smiling
because it looks so luxurious and extra
but it doesn't at home
i don't know it doesn't seem like it's
putting these crushed velvets yesterday
nice at all so even though the house is
kind of empty we've already started to
do changes immediately because i'm like
girl
look at my dining room hi party
are there anything i will like though
come on
oh i like viking i like it
[Applause]
okay that's the kitchen i hate it
[Laughter]
listen i'm scandi gang i like a nice
simple good clean looking kitchen not
this brown [ __ ]
that old people have this is a boomer
kitchen jeffrey
come on
whoa look at all the food i could
finally put in here
that is [ __ ] fresh
we'll stock up soon we've been a little
busy
is that a fridge too yeah it's all empty
right now this is a fridge and freezer
double drainage
is that more fridges how many fragrances
do you have
how many fridges do you need
oh my god that's outrageous
ten fridges the kitchen's one of my
favorite things it's massive
yeah like the first oh my god so this is
our old couch that either you love or
hate it if you've seen it on our channel
oh god look at the tv setup no
no
every time you fail tv shut up i don't
understand this they always put the tv
so high up like bro you're watching like
this
i don't get it they always do it
come on tiny baby tv come on baby tv
you don't need a
nah that's a bad idea i was just
bringing i was just brainstorming what
if you put tv in the fireplace and get
rid of the fireplace just a thought
because you're not gonna need a
fireplace in l.a anyway then they
wouldn't fit if they would look dumb it
was dumb idea but this is also very dumb
it's as dumb i think this is a drying
rack where you put your plates it was
used back in the day so you won't have
to dry your plates after you wash them
he's not using it for anything it's kind
of weird i just want to point that out
even though this house is
a castle
this feels homey
no
no no no it doesn't that silver sucks
my living room is like half this size
now a quarter and it's more like you
know what i mean like when i saw the
outside i was like i know that's a lie
it probably isn't more comfortable holy
[ __ ] it's massive but it feels so homey
madison's the best
um madison's living here now by the way
you guys in two months she's moving in
where are you going to show to your core
now madison you did this what is this
what am i looking at what is that what
is this what are they available what is
all day
this is a couple a cup of coffee how
many you gotta even eat name what is it
how many desks cup look at him hi yes
madison would love to show you her wing
i guess he recently moved in so a lot of
it looks barren so
this is going to be the full like art
room
oh so it's not done yet toys
[Applause]
i don't know how to express my emotions
watching this it's just excess in every
conceivable way
everything
in my brain
can't handle it this is the three-story
willy wonka glass elevator
please do the honors oh my god i'm so
excited again
come on it's an elevator but that is
kind of cool
shane welcome to the star theater
oh
that's [ __ ] huge
geez
it got stars face rock would love that
it got stars in this
what
nice
[Music]
oh god it's so tacky how is this a style
what do you call this style oh they got
a game room and we're gonna put a new
rick and morty pinball here that's
coming for christmas oh can't wait for
that can't wait for that one hell yeah
look at the grapes before you even enter
look at the stainless steel grapes
all right i'll let you do the honors
yeah those grapes
what i'll go because
i'm missing a reference
oh my gosh you might find me in here
just randomly
[Music]
i don't know what to say i i hate it but
i don't want to be mean but i've already
been meaning everything else i don't
know okay so this to me feels like a
house to show that you made it like look
how rich i am and i think a lot of
people have the opinion that if they had
like a big house like this they would be
like yeah
i'll be happy i'll made it but i'd hate
living in this
everything about it like what
okay the pinball machine oh yeah kind of
sick now they're out of the house
[Music]
[Laughter]
if i had a mansion i for sure get like a
home arcade that'd be so that'd be sick
get a home arcade
six computers maxed out all for land
gaming or some [ __ ] like that
but set up in a dope way
hell yeah this is an homage to my old
pink house this will have my old pink
bed in it you see the frame we took some
of the chandeliers out from the kitchen
i hate it
what the hell is this style what is this
there might be a drought
but then there's a pink grout in there
that matches the vault
yes some people still like this to kind
of taste
all right jim okay this is jim
hi welcome to star fitness let me see
your gym membership please oh my god
all right what do we got what have we
got
come on
all jokes aside it was a dream of mine
to have a urinal in my home yes
yes i got one
that urinal that's the dream yeah that
is the drink when you have a urinal you
know you've made it yes
or you could just get a japanese toilet
because you know the lid just got
on its own hmm urinal not necessary
come on
you want your little locker room
no show the gym
you name show it
you show the universal more okay no
dumbbell or rack
he's talking about the urinal this
[ __ ] that's the gym
they got sauna
in the other room and i was so shook
yeah
like i just couldn't believe it was all
happening like how many people live in
this house
how are you gonna use all of this
yes thank you shane we've already
started we're making water yeah massages
over here the facial lady someone in the
jacuzzi i was like this is so crazy so
here's where you get massage therapy
wow
he has a room specific for massage
therapy
yeah hopefully a few of them yeah it was
really windy the other night so it's a
full leaves right now oh it is
how is this real
like it hasn't you know it hasn't
settled is that this uh i mean i don't
hate it from this angle it's kind of
quirky yeah the exterior i mean but i
also still kind of
don't like yeah it's it's all the same
okay
no it's bad it's not good it's bad very
bad
uh
yeah it's not as nothing will ever be
what's her name again i forgot her name
uh
tick-tock girl no
hers is so bad that she just forever
owns that category i don't think we'll
ever find anything as bad as hers
so i'll put jeffrey on e i think that's
fair okay marzia has been begging me to
do
troye sivan's house because she loves
his uh troye sivan not a youtuber
anymore but this is his house tour
ah hey eddie what's up it's troye sivan
this is my house in melbourne i think
please please yeah he's in australia
i have been waiting for this day for my
entire life so
this would be interesting because ken
kennedy's uh he wants to get a house in
australia he moved there he's almost
complaining about the market and it
seems like it's really tough
that's cool
yeah i have been living in america for
the last like maybe like five or six
years it's kind of cool with the
mezzanine very stylish i think it's all
very detailed except the radiator what's
up with that it's so ugly and the floor
that looks maybe that's like some
original floor type of deal first things
first this is like literally the most
comfortable couch in the world i feel
like they oh people are gonna get mad at
me for not dude i can hear how
comfortable that couch looks it is what
the [ __ ] one of my favorite art pieces
in the whole house this is barbara mesh
oh is it all right cool
ikea lamp come on light just kind of
gently fills the room yeah that's cozy
too with these pendants i swear to god
like dude i cannot watch tv shows
anymore because what they do to make the
scenes look better is they always lit
every single light in the house
you'll notice this now because i've said
it but like no one does that no one goes
and lets every single side lamp
automatically i'm like all right turn
this lamp on turn the slime on turn this
lamp no one does that no one has the
time in it to do that every single day
or bother to do it so whenever i see it
in movies i'm like there's no [ __ ]
way they're doing they just bother to
let up every single time they're all
gonna get killed from the monster in the
horror movie
come on come on but it does look cozy
sorry i feel like they kind of look like
alien skin or something they sort of
feel like what i imagine alien skin
would feel like and i love them they
glow at night you guys should have come
at night in all honesty because the
house yeah i bet it will look cozy
actually
uh are we brushing past the alien skin
bitter all right
um this couch is vintage by personal
affair it reminded me of it looks like a
bathtub come around the back you can see
there's like
this white bathtub
situation
it's kind of cool i guess
hey
i'm not sold on it i wouldn't get it
watch out for those pear trees it'll
kill you troy this is my
reading nook or whatever
and it's super comfortable see might say
you're watching this comfortable
comfortable furnitures
girls
you always want the pretty furniture you
always want the good looking furniture
but we guys we want the comfy furniture
can we get both please
nice indoor outdoor living anyway oh
kitchen is cool
okay i see where martial like this now
yes
i'm going to say this a lot but i think
it's my favorite part of the house yeah
kitchen just feels really really chill
we've got this like awesome green stone
yeah that actually works this is a
servery i think it's the technique is
called end block well not solo maps
that's kind of a separate piece of wood
that they stick together no i got that
cut it and you get this like
finish or whatever this situation yeah
that's nice
that's lovely sometimes i stand here and
like serve coffees or whatever to people
if they're in the garden all the
appliances are integrated
and the handles are words
like beer and old take out food i like
that materiality in the kitchen is i
think my favorite in the house we've got
like all this black steel and i love the
way that it shows
i don't even know these like sort of
natural markings yeah i don't have
nothing to fold on it except the
flooring to be honest weirdly there used
to be a toilet here it was still like
the kitchen kind of grossed me out um
and so we we got rid of it and i'm going
to show you where we put it because i
think it's kind of all right good call
there's a little ghost by this artist
named nell it's sand blown glass i just
think it's so cute kind of yeah very
much yeah horrible demon creatures for
no reason but to haunt you someone down
there with no worries or could be
working at my desk you really have a lot
of places to sit down and chill like
damn come on how many you need just
heaps and heaps how many coffee table
books do you have jesus christ not a lot
of people know this about me but i am
very very gay and so just
[Laughter]
look at these
oh god
this is the guest bedroom
is that cork on the ceiling yeah that's
kind of cool
akari lamp so these cork ceilings are
original it is it kind of makes the
whole house feel kind of like a a really
cozy cave and we did the holes in this
like venetian plaster i guess kind of
work for bedroom it's so smooth and soft
and so i feel like everything just kind
of like hugs you at night
troy gets safe you want to be s tucked
in sleep gang hell yeah that's cool i
like the
i guess brass faucet with that stone
could be tacky but it works even the led
light like that it looks great
everything is great i'm not sold on the
furniture per se but they are they suit
him so i got nothing to say about it but
the kitchen and bathrooms are cool we
closed it off because
i needed a bathtub
okay yeah i see one martial like this
this is my yeah it's pretty i don't like
it but i see why marzian likes it you
know when you go to a restaurant and
people are like oh have you been to the
toilet you have to go to the toilet
everyone's gonna carry the levine's
bathroom a little bit so he moved the
bathroom out the horse interesting okay
two handsome men playing handball in a
court and then there's this like weird
sort of spear thing on the side and then
you walk over here
and
hey
spear cool i really love the idea that
this house has had so many lives and
been through kind of
just so much cool
yeah
nice cool garden cool place suits in man
living in literal paradise for
introverts yeah no gaming setup though
and i don't even remember if i saw tv
how he functioned i don't know but i
will rate this
i would rate it beat here but marseille
will kill me so eight tier
yes
anyway that was another youtuber house
or if you enjoyed smash like if you want
more let me know and i'll see you bros
tomorrow with another video breakfast
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this